[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best bi wise fashion tips makeup acts
and so much more we are sure you're
going to love it and be sure to let us
know what you think in the comment
section here for you you never know when
you're going to face a dangerous
situation what you do every day could
even be life-threatening and the first
thing you need to survive is to know
what you're going to do make sure you
watch this video until the end if you
want to have more chances to survive
hola
did you hear about our latest addition
to our family their richest espanol is
the perfect place for all you native
Spanish speakers out there don't speak
Spanish no problem come on over this is
the perfect place to practice amazing
facts interesting people and funny
pictures those ambos aji today we're
showing you 10 tips that may save your
life one day surviving an earthquake you
never know when an earthquake is going
to happen and if you live somewhere
where you're at risk you need to know
what to do in this kind of situation you
only have a few seconds to think so it
is really important that you know how to
do the right thing if you're in a house
don't try to run away there is no way
you can escape the earthquake simply get
on the floor to make sure that you don't
fall and hide under a piece of furniture
like a table cover your head and neck
using your arms and cover your mouth if
you have trouble breathing if the wall
falls you will be protected from it and
you will have a small space to survive
while you wait for rescue however do not
move when the earthquake stops even if
you think you're fine because there
might be some dangerous aftershocks this
is why you want to stay in place for a
minute or two to make sure that you're
safe you will then need to carefully
leave the building before looking at the
damages and wait for help if you're
outside during the earthquake we need to
stay where you are
unless something might fall on you in
this case seek shelter in a wide-open
area no matter what remember the three
words at the national standards for
earthquake safety in the United States
drop cover and hold meeting a stranger
whether it's at a bar or an online
dating app we meet strangers every day
we might want to get the chance to know
them but there are still some things
that you need to keep in mind to make
sure that you're with someone you can
trust if you meet someone online make
sure that they don't know too much
information about you but that you still
know their real name and what they look
like you don't want to meet a 50 year
old weirdo when you're wanting to meet a
young female friend talking on a webcam
before and following them on social
media it could be a good way to know who
they are
then if
you want to meet them make sure you tell
a friend where you're going to go and
with who you're going to be it is even
better if you can text them to say that
you're ok when you meet the stranger
make sure that you use them in a public
place
where there are a lot of people around
they probably won't try to do anything
too weird if there are people nearby and
you'll be able to scream for help if
something happens you could also bring
someone with you if you don't feel safe
in any case follow your intuition
remember that you don't owe them
anything and you can leave whenever you
want being trapped in a falling elevator
this is something that all the Hollywood
movies wanted us to be afraid of the
first thing you need to know is that
elevators are actually really safe most
people who are injured by elevators are
usually construction or maintenance
workers and those who fell down shafts
or who were caught in elevator doors or
between floors anyway you probably don't
remember ever reading news about people
being stuck in a falling elevator so it
proves that it's extremely rare but no
matter what it is important to know what
to do if you're really unlucky don't try
to jump prior to impact you will only
hit your head on the ceiling land badly
and be even more injured actually the
best thing to do is to lie flat on your
back on the floor this position will
spread the force of the impact across
your body and protect your bones from
crushing damage put an arm under your
head to protect it from the impact and
the other over your head to protect it
from falling debris
unfortunately this position is not
perfect your brain and your organs will
absorb the full impact which could lead
to life-threatening injuries and if the
floor is destroyed it could be even more
dangerous for your body but no matter
what lying on the floor is the safest
option you're still too scared just take
the stairs facing the cold you might
underestimate the cold but hypothermia
is the number one thing that is
life-threatening to outdoor recreation
Asst
you don't even need freezing
temperatures to suffer from it and this
is why you need to be really cautious so
if it is windy outside or if you're in
contact with cold water you might need
to do what it takes to stay warm the
first thing you need to do is notice the
signs of hypothermia like a violent
shivering and cold pale skin this is the
first step but then you will see that
mental activity is affected you could
also feel confused sleepy slowed and
have difficulty speaking as soon as you
notice these signs you need to find a
warm place as soon as possible remove
the wet clothes and wrap yourself in
layers of dry warm clothes and blankets
you can also apply warm compresses to
the neck and the chest you can also ask
someone to share their body heat with
you by taking off your clothes and
cuddling however do not use direct heat
or something
that is too hot because it might hurt
you even more don't believe it alcohol
can help you because it only makes
things worse and prepare a warm drink
instead in any case it is always
important to call emergency medical
assistance if you feel like you're
suffering from hypothermia even if you
think you've recovered the damages might
be worse than you think
escaping and sinking if you go on a
bridge or drive by water every day a
life-threatening situation might be
closer than you think it just takes a
second to make the wrong movement and
fall in the water this is why you need
to know what to do and think fast if
your car ever falls in the water the
first thing you need to do is unbuckle
your seatbelt if you want to be able to
escape however don't try to open the
door because water pressure makes it
impossible to do anyway it would just
allow more water to come in and make
your car sink faster instead simply try
to open the window and escape the car a
thinking car will not immediately
submerge so it is the right time for you
to do this however if you can't open the
window you will need to break it go for
the side windows because the windshield
is made to resist impact you can use
your foot and kick at the top of the
window if it doesn't work remove the
headrest from your seat and jam it where
the window meets the door if you're too
slow and can't break the window you will
have to wait for the car to be full of
water before you can open the door and
try to escape no matter what staying
calm is the best way to think fast and
do the right thing being attacked by a
bear you might like nature but it also
comes with a lot of dangerous things
that you need to avoid first you don't
have to worry too much because not all
bears are dangerous
polar bears and brown bears are more
likely to attack but you can be less
scared if you see a black bear the first
thing you need to do is avoid any wild
animal that could be dangerous avoid
places where you can find one and stay
as far from them as you can curiosity is
not your friend in this situation you
should also try to make noise all the
time for example by clapping your hands
or talking so they will stay far from
you avoid having food with you because
they might be attracted to the smell and
carry bear spray with you just in case
if a bear ever sees you pretend that you
are as big as possible that might scare
them and they'll walk away and if they
attack you anyway there are still some
things you could do this is the right
time to use your pepper spray if you
don't have any just don't move so they
won't see you as a threat and it's only
during the attack that you should play
dead so they won't have any interest in
you or maybe the best thing to do is
just go to a zoo if you want to see a
bear escaping a rip current going to the
beach on a beautiful day might become
the worst time of your life if you're
ever stuck in a rip currents but first
what is this thing it's a long and
narrow band of water that can pull
swimmers away from the shore and out to
sea in just a few seconds
and this is what makes them very
dangerous the first thing you need to do
is to stay away from them by identifying
them avoid any channel of water that
looks different from the surrounding as
rip currents are foam here form a quiet
gap in the line of breaking waves or can
be a slightly different color if you
feel a strong pull in shallow water get
out immediately because it's difficult
to swim back when you're deeper if
you're stuck anyway there are some
things you can do first stay calm
because you don't want to waste your
energy the last thing you want to do is
to try to fight the current because it's
useless and it will just make you
exhausted instead you should call for
help and swim parallel to the shore to
escape the current otherwise just try to
float and conserve your energy so you
can wait until the rip current is weaker
in this case you need to be the smartest
not the strongest if you want to make it
out alive eating something toxic
something that you eat or drink every
day could be life-threatening and this
is why it's important to know the limits
to avoid any dangerous situation for
example some fruit seeds like apples and
cherry pits contain a type of hydrogen
cyanide that we call prussic acid this
is a dangerous poison so you should
avoid eating it eating too much rhubarb
nutmeg almonds and potatoes could also
be really dangerous and even water could
be life-threatening if you drink too
many bottles if you think that you push
the limits a little too far it is
important to know the signs of poisoning
it could be a redness around the mouth
and lips a breath that smells like
chemicals vomiting difficulty breathing
drowsiness and confusion if you feel any
of these symptoms after eating something
call the poison center and they will
tell you what to do the most important
symptoms are unconsciousness difficulty
breathing being Restless or agitated or
having a seizure in this situation call
911 immediately because you have not
much time left to live in any case if
you know that you took medications or a
large amount of something dangerous
you should also call for help
immediately you better be safe than
sorry so it's always important to ask
the right questions to make sure that
you're going to be okay noticing a
stroke a stroke can happen out of
nowhere and it's important to notice it
really quickly to avoid any damage
usually you'll be too confused to
clearly understand what happened and
this is why someone should help you and
the best way to save lives is to make
sure that everyone knows the symptoms of
a stroke if you suspect that someone
might not be feeling fine you should do
some tests first ask them to smile if
you notice a droop or the smile is
uneven this is a warning sign
then ask them to raise their arms over
their head if they're not able to raise
one arm if it drops down or if it's not
steady that person might be having a
stroke another thing you should look for
is if they're able to speak ask the
person to repeat something and if it's
hard for them to do that this is a bad
sign if they don't pass any of these
tests you should call 911 immediately
will you wait for the ambulance to come
stay with the person and keep them from
falling or injuring themselves take a
few notes at the time when the stroke
took place and if they take any
medication because this information is
really important but don't give them any
food or medication because it could make
things worse you did your job by calling
9-1-1 and now you just need to wait for
help to come being attacked by an
alligator if you live somewhere where
there are a lot of crocodiles or
alligators knowing these tips might be
the best way to turn the worst day of
your life into just a really bad one the
first thing that you need to do is avoid
these animals so if you know that
there's one nearby
don't try to pet them but stay as far as
you can unfortunately one of them might
surprise you and in this case you need
to run fast but don't run in a straight
line because it will be easier for them
to catch you instead walk in different
directions because the animal won't be
able to turn as fast as you and will
probably give up if you're in the water
you will have to get out of there slowly
but make sure that you remain calm
because splashing might catch their
attention if they already saw you it's
useless to try to swim because they are
faster than you instead try to hit them
on the nose or in the eyes to hurt them
people can also help you by hitting the
head of the crocodile with sticks or
stones in any case after an attack don't
fight back and call 911 immediately are
there any other survival tips that
people should know
don't be try to tell us what it is in
the comment section down below we love
to hear what you think
[Music]